All right, Katie.
Last year, I'm in an Uber
on the way home from work.
As one does.
The Uber driver has got
his crypto account open.
While he's driving.
While he's driving,
and he is showing me all
the money that he's made
on crypto over the last few months.
And I'm not talking Bitcoin or Ether here,
I'm talking coins.
You can say that.
I just did.
Okay.
And he's like, okay, when
it starts, it's so easy.
When it starts going up, you buy,
and then when it gets
really high, you sell.
I've heard that before.
Well, that's what he was doing.
Yeah.
And all I could think of to myself was,
this is the top, you know?
When your Uber driver's
showing you how much money
he's made in crypto and
how you gotta get in on it.
And I'm thinking, this is not
gonna end well for this guy.
And sure enough, here we
are a few months later.
$2 trillion in crypto
value has been wiped out.
And I'm not hearing Uber drivers
talk about their crypto anymore.
Well, if that story's true,
and it sounds super fake,
let's just establish that.
It's true.
I promise it happened.
Okay, well, if it's true,
it actually was pretty close to the top.
If you think about where
we were around November
of last year, close to a
record high on Bitcoin.
And to your point, we've just
seen this tremendous draw down
of wealth since then.
And I actually think that creates
one of the more interesting
moments in crypto.
After the summer we just lived through
where it felt like everything blow up,
now's the moment where the industry
sort of has to decide
where to go from here.
Whether this is a 2018 moment
after that boom and bust,
which went on to build
an even bigger bubble,
or whether we're entering a
phase of the crypto ecosystem
where it's more mature.
So luckily for us, we have eight
episodes to try to do that.
I have all these papers in front of me,
and we're gonna try to
figure out what moment
we're actually in right now.
And funnily enough, we
actually prepared something.
No kidding?
Yeah, we did.
It only took a few months,
but more than $2 trillion in
crypto wealth was wiped out.
We're talking wreckage
that was far and wide here.
Yeah, we got the billionaires on one side,
but we got everyday people
who lost their life savings.
We saw currencies collapse.
There were mass layoffs at companies,
and some of these
companies were once valued
at billions of dollars
declared bankruptcy.
So what happened?
Well, there was the collapse
of this so-called algorithmic stable coin.
And what that did is it
set off this chain reaction
that brought one of the best
known crypto hedge funds
to its knees.
We gotta go back to May to understand
what really happened here.
The collapse of Terra UST.
This is an algorithmic stable coin,
and it once topped the charts.
Now, it's not exactly clear what set off
the slump and demand for UST,
but then we saw this death spiral.
And it knocked UST off its $1 peg.
Think about this as like
the crypto equivalent
of a bank run.
At the same time, crypto
had been falling in price
since the end of last year.
But then as Terra was melting down,
the panic started to spread.
And it dropped the price
of Bitcoin by nearly 30%
in just a week.
The problem is that
lenders were using Bitcoin
for collateral and that
just led to carnage
across the industry.
Take Three Arrows Capital.
It was this previously
invincible hedge fund.
It once managed as much as $10 billion,
and it declared bankruptcy.
This was just a mess,
but it's a mess that
we've gotta make sense of
and we've gotta understand.
A $60 billion collapse of an ecosystem
that led to a massive decline
in the price of Bitcoin.
And then the outright
collapse of companies.
It was contagion,
but it was contagion that raises
really important questions.
What's the collateral
damage to an industry
after an event like this?
And perhaps most importantly,
have people just lost faith in crypto?
All right, we have a lot of questions.
We've got Stacy Marie Ishmael.
She leads crypto coverage for Bloomberg,
arguably the busiest woman at Bloomberg.
It's been a moment.
And I guess when I think
back to the summer of 2021,
that run up to last November
where we reached the
record high in Bitcoin,
one of the big bullish mantras
was institutional adoptions,
sort of traditional Wall
Street embracing crypto.
And when you say that
we're kind of learning
the lessons of 2008, what is
the reputational damage here?
Is that no longer really
a narrative that holds?
It's been interesting to
see institutions plunge in,
not just like a toe in the water,
at the same time that retail investors
are a little bit more skittish
and a little bit more inclined
to sit on the sidelines.
So you know, just in the past six months,
you've had BlackRock announce
a partnership with Coinbase,
you've had Goldman Sachs make
certain types of derivatives
available to clients.
Even more recently, you have
kind of Citadel, Fidelity,
and others saying they're
gonna back something
like a crypto esque exchange program.
So I do think that one of
the interesting features
of this institutional
adoption is they're like,
we're already regulated.
We know how to do this.
We have all of the available licenses.
We understand how to man manage risk,
and they're seeing opportunities.
Is there concern that right
now the everyday person,
the normal retail person,
is just completely scared away
and is going to potentially
miss an opportunity
because they got worried about
what happened post Matt Damon
and they're just saying,
I'm not gonna touch this stuff anymore.
There's a few different ways
that we're thinking about that.
On the one hand, you know, if you were a
to the moon, yield farming,
I'm looking at 19 different
protocols, you know,
you're like, yeah, down
with decentralization.
On the other hand, if
you're somebody who watched
perhaps your friends, perhaps
your family, perhaps yourself,
lose your life savings in
something like Voyager or Celsius,
then maybe you're gonna look at a Citadel
or a Fidelity or a BlackRock and be like,
they seem like they
know what they're doing.
Their presence might be reassuring to you.
So you've got sort of competing dynamics
in the market at the same time.
Sort of the adults in the room.
That's what they would like you to say.
Yeah, here I am saying
it, so there you go.
I am curious though,
I mean it feels like a lot of the chaos,
the contagion was centered
around these crypto lenders.
And I'd love if you could
bring out your crystal ball
and gaze into it and tell us,
are we ever gonna go back to
the days of like 18% returns
or lending returns, or is that over?
If I can answer this question accurately,
I'd be in a very different job.
However, I will say that as a person
who covered the financial crisis,
for a while they were like,
we'll never go back to X, Y, Z.
And then like three years later,
somebody was like, I've got
this really exotic product
I wanna sell you.
And the memories and the timelines
that we tend to operate on in crypto
are even shorter, right?
Where sort of in the dying embers of Luna
and the associated stable coin,
you had other folks being like,
this is why our algorithmic
stable coin is gonna be fine.
So I think there is an
an kind of an inertia
built into the system of
anything that we invent
can only be positive unless
there's widespread evidence
to the contrary, and
then we'll just do V2.
Okay, so for the past few years,
people in the space have been telling me
when I don't understand something,
it's like, it's the early
days of the internet.
This is like the 1990s when, you know,
Andreessen had just invented Netscape.
And you know, we're trying to figure out
what you can do with this thing.
If that's accurate, did what we see
in the early part of 2022, the explosion,
was that the.com bust?
One of the things about the.com bust
is there were clear winners
that emerged from it,
but you couldn't really
tell who those winners would
be at the time.
And so I do think that
some of the immediate
speculative excess got
wrong out of the market
very hard and very fast and very painfully
for a lot of people involved.
But you know, it took years for Amazon
to become Amazon and it took
a while for people to be like,
ah, pets.com is pets.com.
And we are still in sort of
the immediate aftermath of that
where it's like you
don't know who the Amazon
is gonna be and who the pets.com is.
Right, I mean, Amazon's actually only been
a profitable company reliably
for not that many years.
Exactly.
So there was this really
grim time a few months ago
when things were crashing.
Message boards were filled with people,
anecdotes of people who lost everything.
Our colleagues here at
Bloomberg published a story
about people who lost
everything with Voyager.
I mean, there were people who were talking
about self-harm in these forums.
And I'm just wondering what
we've heard from the industry
over that period of time.
I wouldn't say there's been
a ton of self-flagellation
or even kind of explicit, whoops, our bad.
It's much more around, well, one,
a lot of people are getting sued.
And when you're being sued
actively by thousands of people,
it is perhaps against
the advice of counsel
to be like, well, we made mistakes
because that would be appearing
to admit guilt of some kind.
Makes sense.
But I also think there's a
nihilistic streak in crypto
that suggests that, well,
you should have known
what you were getting into.
Like, how come you invested more money
than you could afford?
That's on you.
If you were margin and
leveraged up to your eyeballs,
that's on you.
We didn't tell you to put
your life savings in crypto.
And I do think that's a
problem for the industry
because it's the kind of
rhetoric that regulators
do not seem best pleased by
because it reminds them of
things like the earlier days
of sports betting and gambling
before those were recognized as having
potentially addictive properties
and the messaging around
that really had to change.
So I do think there has
been an insufficient
amount of contrition
relative to the amount
of boosting that there was
by a lot of these folks.
What's happened instead is
people are just deleting tweets,
taking down YouTube videos, being like,
haha just kidding, JK.
And I don't think that that is necessarily
endearing themselves to the
people who did lose everything.
But again, there's always
a new buyer, right?
There's always somebody who's
coming in for the first time.
And I worry about that new buyer.
With us now, Meltem Demirors,
extremely cool woman.
Also the chief strategy
officer of CoinShares.
Meltem, when we think
about the past few months,
really even the past few
years we extended out,
people, cranks have been warning
that this would end in tears.
Basically this big run up
we saw across the ecosystem.
But when you think about
what actually happened,
the way that the cards
fell, how obvious was it?
Did it happen in the way
that maybe had been expected?
Yes and no.
I think there were always,
as early as 2018, 2019
when the derivative
side of Bitcoin markets
and crypto markets more broadly
really started to take off
and institutional lending
started to emerge.
One of the common
narratives in the media was,
oh, leverage is gonna be
the undoing of crypto.
And as we've talked about before,
in crypto markets, leverage
functions very differently
than in traditional markets.
In traditional markets, you
can use existing securities.
What we actually ended up seeing,
there were all of these rumors,
all of this speculation
in traditional media
around decentralized finance
or on chain financial products
being the undoing of crypto.
And very ironically or sort
of an interesting twist,
it ended up being the application
of traditional lending models,
i.e. uncollateralized or
under collateralized lending
that caused this massive wave of washouts.
Were you guys exposed to that at all?
You know, CoinShares or
in ventured investments
that you've done?
Yeah, so we had minimal exposure.
We had a small amount
of exposure to Terra,
which was the Luna stable coin,
which were publicly listed.
So it was in our Q2 financials,
had very little impact on our business.
So knock on wood and congrats
to our risk management team
for doing a good job there.
And then the big part of the ecosystem
I'm still concerned
about is crypto miners.
Wait, why?
So in the mining business model,
mining is an interesting sort of area,
and I come from the oil and gas industry.
So we're accustomed in
the oil and gas industry.
Like real mining, like real digging.
Real mining, real digging.
No, I'm not talking computers here.
We're talking drills.
Trucks as big
as a two story house, drills, correct.
If you've never seen a Christmas tree,
which is the thing that goes on top
of a wellhead, highly recommend.
You know what?
Tell me.
My TikTok and Instagram
are like all people
doing oil drilling.
What does that say?
I don't know.
How did that algorithm get there?
It's like, I like mechanical things,
so it's like--
Tim likes planes.
Yeah, it's like airplanes
and like oil rigs and stuff.
So I feel like I've learned a little bit.
Real mining.
So the challenge with real mining
is it's very capital intensive
because you have to buy ASICs,
these specialized
semiconductors used for mining,
or GPUs in the case of Ethereum or FPGAs
in the case of zero knowledge proofs.
You buy physical stuff.
And that physical stuff's expensive.
And when you raise capital,
and in particular venture capital,
people don't necessarily
wanna give you money
to buy a bunch of depreciating hardware.
So you finance it.
There's a lot of specialized
lenders in the industry
who specialize in lending using
the actual chips themselves
as the collateral.
So if I wanna borrow say $500 million
to build a new data center
to mine a cryptocurrency,
I may pledge those machines as collateral
to secure the loan.
So there's this interesting
capital recursive
that starts to happen.
And what also happens is
you have operating expenses.
Your operating expense
is the cost of energy.
And no matter what type of compute you do,
all computing requires energy, right?
Energy and a semiconductor.
And so the challenge is
energy prices are rising.
A lot of the contracts that
facilities have in place,
these power purchasing agreement or PPAs
were not well negotiated
because a lot of people
in the crypto mining
space aren't necessarily
from the traditional infrastructure space.
And so energy price is rising,
semiconductor price is dropping.
So the value of your collateral
that secured your loan
is going down.
They don't have collateral
to top up the loan.
So I end up having to sell Bitcoin
at greatly reduced prices.
And the price to mine a
bitcoin then starts to exceed
the profit they make.
So it creates this really
interesting sustainable
finance challenge where
the fundamental economics
of the business stop working.
But in a sense, that's actually similar
to what happens with real oil and gas.
Absolutely.
So if the price of oil falls below--
We saw this with natural gas, right?
Shell gas, right?
If it gets too low,
then it's not worth it
to actually extract it.
Exactly, so you know,
Shell gas probably five or
$6 per million cubic feet
to get out of the ground,
and gas prices for a
long time were two to $3.
So those economics don't work.
So what's that number for Bitcoin?
For Bitcoin right now, the
cost to mine a Bitcoin,
it really varies, right?
So the operational
efficiencies really depend
on how you set up your infrastructure,
what your power costs are,
what your interest rates
are on your machines,
what your cost of equity is
on other capital you raise.
People always Tell me to zoom out though,
like when it comes to the
inflation hedge argument.
Can we put it to bed though?
Can we agree that it's
not an inflation hedge?
No, 'cause I also, I'm
gonna go with the zoom out.
I think the challenge is
Bitcoin has never existed
in an inflationary environment
until roughly nine months ago.
So I do think we need to
give it a bit more time.
I've never existed in an
inflationary environment.
Same.
Yeah.
Although if we look back at the data,
if we zoom out enough.
Oh my gosh, yeah.
You're not gonna get to
the year that she was born.
There was still no inflation, right?
No inflation.
Okay.
But there has been inflation
in in certain areas
and deflation in other areas, right?
Thanks to technology innovation, right?
Amazing thing.
So I think those three
factors taken together
just create a lot of uncertainty.
And then I do think the one thing
that we don't talk about enough,
and again at Coinshare, we
have an amazing research team.
People always try to find factors, right?
And understand, okay, what
factors are going to influence
price direction on this asset class?
So much of it is narrative driven.
So much of it is psychology driven.
And I do think there is an
element of religious belief
that underpins a lot of this as well.
Well, I wanna get to that religious belief
because we saw a lot of
excitement in the last year
when we saw record highs,
not just for Bitcoin
and for Ether, but for--
Everything.
coins.
Number go up, baby.
Yeah, and I'm wondering if the industry,
if you think the industry needs
to apologize for anything.
Okay, so this is a really
interesting question,
and this again is where I think
the consumer protection debate comes in.
So on the one hand,
the reason that we have a
lot of the securities laws
and capital markets laws
we do in the United States
is a regulator or an external body
doesn't necessarily have
the authority to say,
this is good, this is bad.
What they have the authority to say is,
here are the rules, here's
the information we need,
this is what needs to be provided, right?
Being publicly listed is
not a barometer of quality,
it's a barometer of you having filled out
the appropriate paperwork and
having provided financials
and a level of transparency
that will allow investors
to make an informed decision, right?
So this is about people
making informed decisions.
I think the challenge with
crypto is so many people
in 2021 especially,
and we saw this in 2018
and before that in 2014,
so many people view crypto
and so many people online
marketed crypto as a
way to get rich quick.
So people were marketing
a lot of these things
as an easy button.
And as you and I and everyone knows,
there is no easy button.
And I think the challenge
is that a lot of people
had incentives to market
certain things as safe
to encourage people to
invest in certain things.
And also people don't
wanna do their diligence.
Again, the point I'm making
and what I'm trying to illustrate
is this is not a phenomenon
that's unique to crypto.
It exists in all parts of the market.
Can I just say to maybe defend
the crypto industry a little bit more,
think about the traditional
currency industry.
4X scammers on Instagram.
I just can't, before
basically crypto exploded
the way it did in the pandemic,
some of my favorite accounts on Instagram
were these like 4X scammers
flexing their Guccis
and their Ferraris.
On the private jet.
Yes, I love.
Piles of cash.
I think you make
a good point though, but
you're not seeing those
advertised in the Super Bowl.
No, no, but it exists.
So it did reach a different level
of the cultural zeitgeist.
But are you saying,
well, I mean a 4X scammer is different
from like Coinbase buying a Super Bowl ad.
Right.
Which by the way, I
loved that Super Bowl ad.
Was that the QR code?
It was was just a QR code bouncing around.
It's kind of a baller move
to spend millions of dollars
on a little bouncy QR code.
So it sounds like, I
mean, in your opinion,
the industry does not have
anything to apologize for?
It's more like.
I think apologize as a challenging a word.
I think there's certain
individuals who maybe behaved
in a way that is not
great, but I'm not a judge,
I'm not a jury, I'm not an executioner.
I do my best to not
engage in that behavior.
I never tell people invest
in this, buy this, do this.
So I can't speak for that.
I'm not the moral compass of the industry.
Again, another challenge,
it's decentralized.
It's leaderless by its very nature.
I think it's very difficult for anyone,
individual or entity to sort
of claim moral superiority,
including the US government, by the way,
for this very precise reason it started.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a slippery slope.
I understand what you're
trying to arrive at.
I do think that certain
executives of certain companies
that lost millions, tens of millions,
billions of dollars of consumer's funds,
they definitely have explaining to do.
And I do think they'll be held to account
because a company exists
under a legal structure
in a jurisdiction with protocols.
But you have a really cool story
where you recognized something early on
when it came to Bitcoin.
What did you see?
When did you see it?
And I mean, yeah, and how
much Bitcoin did you buy then?
Nice try, IRS.
I'm joking.
Okay, you're not gonna tell us
how much Bitcoin you bought.
No, I'm never gonna tell you that.
Okay, but what was the price of Bitcoin
when you first got in?
When I got in, it was around $150.
And then I went through a period where
when I first started working,
I was making less than I
had before grad school.
And I was in a lot of debt
because I had had a
scholarship from my company
to go to grad school and
then I didn't come back.
So I lived in a rat infested
apartment in New York
and I used every paycheck
to buy more Bitcoin.
Wow.
And then the price of Bitcoin
went from $300 to $120.
And I did not feel great
about my life choices.
But it was really funny
because people look at it now
and they're like, oh, did
you have some intuition?
I'm like, no, I just thought
it was really interesting
the people I was interacting with,
like I'd never interacted with people
like that before professionally.
And I was like, this is wild.
It's fun.
It's really crazy and insane.
See, I would've said yes,
I did have intuition,
and I can see the future.
No, I'll be very honest.
And you're not a part of it.
And It was fun.
You know what I miss?
There is a certain joy
in believing something
that no one else believes in
and willing to grind to
prove that you were right.
Are those days over though?
No.
Where you could make those
kind of outsized returns
on a coin or crypto?
I don't think it's a coin anymore.
I think where the world is shifting to,
I do think what is gonna
generate outsize returns
is capturing and creating,
by the way, trends.
So I do think identifying
emerging cultural movements
or communities early and investing
in the financialization of
those cultural movements
is gonna be a huge thematic trend.
And so that is really interesting.
It's one that a lot of
people aren't talking about,
aren't looking at.
So I do think there's still opportunities.
They're just not going to be as easy
'cause there's a lot more capital,
there's a lot more people.
So you have to be willing to
go where other people won't go.
And lucky for me, I like
really weird people.
I like really weird things,
and I'm willing to bet
enormous amounts of money
on really crazy ideas.
But I think that's where the
returns will continue to be.
Meltem Demirors, it's great to see you.
Great to see you.
Just influencing.
This was fun.
That went okay.
Yeah, that was okay.
Yeah.
We should do it again.
I'm down.
All right.
Cool, let's do it.
All right, see ya.